Thank You great to be back that's me
brewster kahle founder of the internet
archive so in general the Internet
Archive has been trying to digitize the
past and put it online for free public
access but we've also been then trying
to take the born digital and make it
permanent can we and as was related this
is a forward-looking talk in a couple of
different ways its forward-looking in
the how should things be done but also
because it doesn't exist yet which I
really like to talk about but it's
actually something doesn't exist yet but
I'm hoping to cost to exist by giving
this talk we've spent the last 25 years
of our lives putting our lives into the
world wide web by coat putting ourselves
trusting the world wide web with our
thoughts our dreams our ideas our papers
we've been putting it all out there
which has been fabulous but there are
some problems the the way the web is
coded really determines the way we live
our lives online so as friend and and
and hero Larry Lessig puts it code is
law so the way the web is coated really
determines how we live our lives online
yet how the web is coded should have our
values baked into it whether it's
freedom of expression or universal
access to all knowledge the privacy
structures that we we we want to live in
but it doesn't we now know it really
doesn't it doesn't have a lot of those
things but the web is big so the world
wide web we now we collect about a
billion pages every week of the World
Wide Web adding it and learning about it
now about 450 billion pages in the
Wayback Machine so it's it's huge but we
also know that the life of a web page is
about a hundred days before it's either
changed or it's deleted so it's flipping
on and off servers all the time also he
is massively available right you can now
get access you can just type in a URL
someplace in Korea fantastic you're just
beaming over there you're getting
whatever it is you want and all those
things and so it's a massively available
unless you live in China where the
internet archive the New York Times are
blocked we're currently blocked we
believe in most of Russia and India goes
in block goes in on blocks and unblocks
things so the internet is not reliable
in any sort of durably accessible or
over space or time it's also not private
I had a chilling time reading an article
in the intercept based on Snowden's
revelations that the GCHQ watched
everyone using WikiLeaks the IP
addresses which are personally
identifiable in most are all
circumstances and I then gave those to
the NSA for further interrogation the
NSA then use those and that they went
those people went to WikiLeaks justified
their spying on them inside the United
States libraries have had a long history
of grappling with reader privacy the
idea of people being rounded up for what
it is they've read has a long and
dreadful history and so we have built a
system and it is being currently used in
this way to on to target people based on
what it is they now read yeah you know I
have known each other a long time but
when I talk about the archive the area's
more remote from the Bay Area they
actually think you're funded by the CIA
or the NSA I actually incorrect but I'm
but I think they should be worried about
me too right I mean it's not like oh
well glad brochures doing it he's
benevolent he wouldn't do anything
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh right no we have to
worry about these these particular
issues but the third aspect of the web
whether it's a reliable private it is
fun right we basically built something
that is
so interesting and fun to play with the
P and malleable the people have been
bowing lip Eiling into the web and doing
interesting things with it so out of the
big three the goals I would suggest
reliability private and fun we got one
out of three I would suggest we shoot
for higher than that I suggest it's now
time to go for all three of these and
been trying to figure out how we might
be able to do this this is a call for a
distributed web so this distributed web
would involve peer-to-peer and
structures that would be sort of newer
structures but I'd suggest it's doable
and some of the pieces are being done
and that's what this talk is towards
what what do I mean by distributed so
distributed on people say well the world
wide web is distribute it's all over the
place it's like yeah yes and no it's um
if you were to take any particular piece
of hardware out you would nail a website
for instance or a user or if you put a
boundary right in front of a website you
can see everybody that's going in and
out of it there's partition abola it's
it's fragile in that way so let's talk
about what does distributed really mean
in this context would be something like
the internet so the Internet it takes a
UH and its design we're told that any
particular part of it could be nuked
literally and it would still route
around and work so it doesn't require
any particular piece of it to work of
course if you partition it a novel it
will eventually die but the internet
itself and actually is a talk and I
confirmed it with with Vint Cerf that it
took him about a year being in pretty
much a closed room with a bunch of very
smart people on small group of people to
try to make the Internet protocols such
that it worked in a distributed way it
is harder to build a distributed system
than it is to build sort of a
point-to-point system like the World
Wide Web the World Wide Web fabulous Tim
Berners they did a great job by making
something really simple you could write
back in the day you could go and write a
web server and a few dozen lines of Perl
code and it would be kind of up and
and you could get it going it is harder
to build a distributed system let's take
another example of a distributed system
that and the way I'd like to look at it
let's take the amazon cloud amazon cloud
is made up of data centers that are all
over the world and they've got the
technologies to make it so that if a web
server service starts to get popular it
starts to replicate itself and go on to
more hardware if parts of the hardware
go down it goes and fixes it if it if
there's more people in different area
using the service it migrates so they've
got an ability to do a distributed
system of computational structure on the
Amazon Cloud which is fantastic what if
we could make the world wide web kind of
like that for everybody is there a way
of making the next generation website
without having it be all owned and
operated by corporation be able to
operate in some of those ways if we're
going to start going down you know the
sort of the punch list of sort of what
do we want out of out of the web
originally and certainly at this point
and post Snowden we would like to make
it so that it has reader privacy baked
in so that it really is very difficult
on to make to figure out what it is any
particular person has seen or take on
the website what are all the people that
have seen that website is there a
mechanism of trying to do that I this
turns out to be one of the hardest
features to try to figure out how to
build into this which is odd for me
because in the physical world it used to
be publishing anonymously I was hard but
reading anonymously was easy you know
you put in a brown paper bag and you
know pass it around and and it and that
was sort of worked but actually
publishing now anonymously on the World
Wide Web I would suggest is easier to
figure out how to make that happen than
it is to make reading anonymous but i'd
say it's particularly important let's go
for another couple features let's build
in a time axis this time the worldwide
the wayback machine is a kludge put on
top of the world wide web to try to give
it a time axis and it only works kind of
barely
um it's it's it tries to say snapshots
of web pages so they're not living
websites they're actually just snapshots
of what they look like and it's and you
have to know to go there it's not even
built into the browser's yet such that
you hit a 404 it goes to the Wayback
Machine so it's not even woven in so the
wayback machine is a good start but
we're really suffering I suggest that
the original architecture of the web did
never had a time axis in it it was as if
every day is a new day there is no
previous edition of a book it's like the
current book is the only book there it
is right everything in the past has been
erased so let's build in a time axis
into the world may be kind of like a get
or something like that so you can see or
wikipedia has it on a centralized basis
another thing we're suffering from is we
don't have a mechanism to make it so you
can charge for things on the world wide
web in any way worthwhile it just
doesn't work um you can go and make
money by having a mogul have ads that
are on it or you can kind of sell your
stuff through through amazon but it
doesn't seem to work terribly terribly
well okay so that's my wish list all the
technologies that Tim berners-lee had
available to him 25 years ago was was
reverse can't compared to what we've got
now so some of the fun things that I've
seen that we have now as building blocks
that we can use I'd say the leading one
is JavaScript what a mind blow
javascript has a capability when I the
ha moment for me was seeing an IBM PC or
an apple to boot in my browser in
JavaScript and it so it booted up um and
then it loaded virtual floppy and i was
playing oregon trail and the idea that
that was working inside JavaScript that
a computer maybe 10 15 years ago was
running at speed in JavaScript cross
compiled from C meant that we've gotten
some place we can distribute code very
easily and smoothly and build that as an
operating system we've also got some
other technologies we've got public and
private key encryption that wasn't
available to us
back then it existed but it was illegal
to distribute it the NSA basically
called an ammunition and it was a big
problem until the crypto Wars in the
1990s and basically been surf had to go
and build an unencrypted internet which
was you know oops and the World Wide Web
didn't have it built in at all we have
blockchain that can go and help with
some of the distributed nature of things
like naming and we have Bitcoin that
make it so that we can actually do a
distributed system of payment structures
so we've gotten some technologies that
we can play with okay so err we're so
far right oh gosh glad I came to a
lecture about a guy wishing something
existed well there are a lot of people
working on pieces of the project but I
don't think they're woven together very
well as I've started to talk to people
about this I've been finding that the
more and more of these things parts of
it exists there's Malstrom by BitTorrent
and now I think they just renamed it
surf which is a browser that works out
of torrents made safe namecoin ephemeral
bitcoin for payments I PFS Juan Bennett
gave a talk here a couple of weeks ago
he's doing fabulous things in the whole
area of making a peer-to-peer file
system so it just looks like a file
system to you but it served in a
peer-to-peer structure and it works are
really quite well so there are a lot of
these technologies where people are
coming at the distributed nature and
doing the hard work of making it so that
there's no centralized points of control
and making these works so what what what
about a bold goal to try to weave things
together towards something that would be
understandable I am going to suggest
what we want is WordPress but
distributed according to some statistics
twenty five percent of all websites are
WordPress websites I mean it's just it's
a very popular easy-to-use tool you can
just go and login to wordpress.com and
start up this thing or you can download
the tool and you can run it and you can
set up your own themes you have
different people have different roles
there are people that can go and post to
it and you can delegate authority so it
has identity system it has themes it's
got hosting
it's even got a distributed what if we
could do make it that easy but to make
it so that our website has those basic
principles of reliability privacy and
still fun what would it take to do it so
here's the the pieces that i would
suggest are necessary there can't be a
new browser it has to work on your phone
in fact it has to be done in such a way
that whoever controls your phone which
is not you um can't turn it off right
can't say oh we don't like that
distributed web so it has to be no
browser no plugins no nothing has to
have good names it's easy to use it has
to be on top of the existing web so you
use your existing browser and you're now
using a distributed website it just
plain works has to be snappy awesome
I'll has to be fun in that sort of cool
internet kind of way and if we really do
our job right we get these extra bonus
points if we can get some payments and
tip system built in and a versioning
system I'm going to suggest that each
one of these is popular and it's going
to possible and I'm just going to step
through them let's go and take the the
first one which is can can we make it
work in a browser so there is a couple
of things that we're missing out of
making a browser to be able to work with
a distributed website this would be a
website that doesn't exist in any
particular place this is a website
that's distributed in a peer-to-peer
system the more people using that
website the more servers there are the
more people are reading the website the
more people serving it there's nothing
you can go and do to go and take out a
particular piece of hardware and that
website goes away that if we can go and
build a distributed web structure that
works with all those different things we
can make it go can you do this on top of
a normal browser and with the
combination of WebRTC which is a
peer-to-peer oriented structure for
opening a socket to another browser plus
the power of JavaScript the answer is
yes you can actually there is a guy
that's written the BitTorrent protocol
in JavaScript so the idea of building at
that level is doable also as I mentioned
the idea of running CD ROM based of
games and having them look awesome and
play in JavaScript
is a reality so the performance the
capabilities of JavaScript i would say
normal browser yes that we could make it
so that if browser manufacturer is going
to make it work for getting to wells
fargo they're going to be able to make
it work for the distributed web which is
very helpful to go and make sure that we
can't be locked out um demo okay so i'm
going to demo a very short piece of this
and i'm going to do the thing that most
people at given talks never want to do
which is a live demo in front of all so
if this works you're going to have to
applause okay so what is this i asked a
programmer announced a time to take my
blog which is written on wordpress and
try to make it work in this peer-to-peer
structure basically make it so that it
doesn't have a server anymore but still
works and what does work mean in this
sense it doesn't have identities doesn't
have a lot of things but it has the
basic pages um and it has a search
engine that actually works is because
there's you know usually some server
side things like a database or a search
engine and basically he's written a
search engine such that it is in
JavaScript with its index so if this
works um then I demand applause okay and
okay browser and well works is not quite
there yet oh let's see I at the to go to
mirror display I guess so all right Tata
okay so what you're seeing here is my
blog that the top it's actually a
gateway if I were running the code on my
machine which I can do very easily and
start it up then I would actually use my
own as part of note of the network and
it's got a hash
four of the my website address so this
doesn't have the easy names yet that we
need but it's basically running out of a
peer-to-peer system and if I go to a I'm
actually typing in and using a search
engine that's running completely locally
so you know this is not you say ok
there's another another piece okay I
could look around in my blog and be able
to see um a website that's running in a
peer-to-peer mode there is no server and
it's actually pretty uh pretty snappy
and and pretty fun to use so uh this is
a mere a separate display see if I get
this back to way back I'm not back hello
I'm kind of back ago I add it for a
moment so I don't want a mirror you just
use a separate display all right okay so
um and there's another sort of how I can
use my own local machine if I start up
the IP FS demon I've also gone and taken
this and moved it into Malstrom into a
bittorrent that moves around as a bit
torn from place to place and as multiple
places and then I run it through a
browser that can go and source things
not just through https but through the
BitTorrent protocol so the idea of using
the bit the peer-to-peer system is is
actually that part is working we also
need any easy name system for instance
it would be great if you just say
Brewster's blogged on NL or something
like that and have that work so we'd
like a really distributed name
that is different from the DNS in sense
that we wouldn't have I can and we have
a mechanism of having it so that
websites don't get shuddered based on
offending some power that be we got a
call at the Internet Archive where the
number two hundred and fiftieth most
popular website and it we got a contact
from network solutions which I don't
even think was our-our did our registrar
and they said we got a complaint this
morning that you're hosting something
that's not good and we're going to turn
off your website in two hours I said
what are you talking about and um and so
I had to get eff on to go and call them
into the right you know calm them down
about whatever but the idea that there's
some low-level droid and network
solution that can go and shut off a 200
the number 250 website based on somebody
sending an email about something is a
little scary and precarious state so
let's do a better name system than that
we also want performance and versions
this thing has to be snappy and one
thing that most people you use
bittorrent say it's it's not snappy it
really doesn't work terribly well here I
would suggest we could use our cultural
institutions like the Internet Archive
to play a role of playing host that we
would be very interested the internet
archive is in basically having copies of
living websites what would be much
better for us than taking snapshots of
existing websites as we'd like to have
living websites libraries take works
from professors and then put them on
shelves in such a way that they can go
be used after the professor wants to
move on to something else why can't we
do that with websites now right now you
have websites that are a part of your
project or whatever and then when the
funding runs out it's a problem because
a lot of people are starting to depend
on it well there might be copies in the
wayback machine but it's just snapshots
it's not a living website you try to get
somebody to take over take it over and
all of that is fairly difficult to do
can we make archival websites from the
beginning can we make it so that web
site's live
in multiple places including and
cultural institutions such as the
internet archive there are other
organizations that would be very
interested in performing the seeding
role the hosting role of these
distributed websites and it would be the
ISPs if you were able to be an ISP that
would offer improved performance by
having a cache of living websites closer
to your users why not a petabyte just
doesn't cost that much anymore so going
and making it so that it's faster for
your users and also make the web more
reliable that can work and the idea of
versions is sort of built into this
because sort of every website version is
copied around it with these hashes and
so there's a concept of what's the
newest but you can go and look at the
past versions in just the same way that
you can look at the current version so
if we build this right we have versions
we have snappy performance we have
cultural institutions playing a living
actual role in this is PS going and
helping build distributed caching
environments without having to be
permission door a CDM it's sort of
building in cdns into the existing
system updates but distributed how do we
do this one of the problems in
bittorrent tends to be that you're
looking at a hash of the contents and so
the contents change you're not pointing
at it anymore on there's been a couple
of different approaches towards how do
you do this naming system so you have a
hash that points to a something that can
mutate underneath it and I PFS right now
I think has the best version of that but
you need this otherwise you're just
everything you put up is completely
static which is the problem we have with
bit torrents we made everything in the
internet archive all public materials
petabytes of it available via BitTorrent
and people go and download those but if
the materials are updated then it's kind
of a problem because people don't know
what the newest version is without going
back to the web so we have to build in
updates structures into this distributed
identity system how do we make it so
that you have your identity so that your
blog knows it's you again and you can
delegate to other people but say let's
make it a suit
anonymous system so that your it's
enduringly know that it's you but it may
you may have want to disavow yourself of
that particular identity in the future
we know how to do these things we just
didn't build it in very well and the
idea of counting on a Facebook or Google
identity as being your identity is kind
of creepy in all of the ways that you'd
kind of imagine well actually probably
you guys wouldn't imagine because you're
in Silicon Valley sounds like with all
your friends but imagine other parts of
the world where it's not necessarily a
built in part of your world I would
suggest we can do something interesting
though at this juncture what you'd use
is assign everything so everything is
signed by the person that wrote it and
using a public/private key pair there is
a public/private key pair in widespread
use its bitcoin and bitcoin their
address structure has got a bounty for
somebody that can try to break it if you
can break that system you can get very
very wealthy on the by going stealing
other people's bitcoins so there's a big
bounty towards keeping that system
secure why don't we just use those
address pairs there's all the tools to
go and generate those address pairs of
internet of Bitcoin addresses and the
private keys great so that can work um
that we basically be able to use them
another nice thing you get from it is if
you sign things using your Bitcoin
address you know who you could tip so
you'd know who wrote something and you'd
have a direct mechanism right away of
being able to go and plunk money into
them if they wanted the one of the
donations smarter people and I are
working on how we can take the next step
to go and encrypt materials such that if
you pay a certain number of say bitcoins
or whatever comes next and distributed
currencies that you can then unlock it
and be able to see it so you might be
able have a distributed mechanism
charging for the distribution of
materials if we pick our identity system
well so i would like to argue that we
can have WordPress but distributed so
just going down the list of sort of the
necessary technologies I've seen all of
the pieces in in despair
early I worked with the different
communities to see these things
basically work they're not working
together yet and that's why I'm here and
talking about this is to try to spirit
us towards building a distributed web
that brings us privacy it brings us
reliability in space and time to the
reliability in terms of versions time no
space no matter where you are that you'd
be able to get a reliable access the
idea is to lock the web open can we make
openness irrevocable can we bake the
First Amendment into the code itself can
we make it so that our values of privacy
universal access to all knowledge are
built into our tools in such a way that
it becomes irrevocable that it's just
the way the system works and then where
I suggest ready for the next step a
distributed web this is probably not
going to be built by an Internet Archive
alone it needs to be seen as desirable
by another bunch of players started to
talk about it with different folks where
they're starting to zoloft certain
pieces of it and if I'm successful will
rally behind and make something that's
as easy and fun to use as the current
web but has these other characteristics
thank you very much wait yes there you
been stupid just going say no no no all
through my talk
our region's okay first my credentials
are talking but we as a month program
here of been running what is once the
Loch sport what does that stand for our
puppies keeps on saying we've been
running a a distributed web archiving
system now for 17 years yes and it's
really hard there are you can be skating
over a huge number of problems that and
you these are problems that people have
been working on on for a long time so
for example you're trying to build this
out of injecting coding people's
browsers yes for at least the last
decade van Jacobson has been and others
have been trying to build this as a
replacement for IP doing exactly what
you want it's called it was it used to
be called content centric networking and
now it's it's one of the four big NSF
future internet funded project and it's
really hard there's a lot of very
difficult crypto that's needed in order
to make this work and people have been
working on this for a long time it's not
I'm objecting to building a version of
this by building into people's browsers
and layering it on top of IP but you
need to be looking at what a how it
would work once we can get rid of IP and
do this just this stuff at the IP level
instead of by layering it on top of IP
because as we see for example with tall
and with Bitcoin the blockchain there
are real problems in building this kind
of system on top of a system which
actually reveals a lot about what's
going on and vanced team at USC or
wherever and I think they are now they
be they've been designing the system so
that you can run an IP on top of their
system you can run their system on top
of IP
and it doesn't reveal even the went
wrong why people i'm going to hand out
of the slider either so it's a layer yes
that people haven't worked on these
things and that they're hard is true all
the pieces though i think are close to
being able to be woven together into
things that would be useful enough that
that would cause a positive loop as i
said i'm not against i think it's a very
good idea it's the way that vans been
working layering this stuff on IP as an
interim measure i'm just saying there
are real problems with entry systems
getting very popular let's talk about
ifs a part for example and you need to
be looking at how it would work once
it's once i peek underneath goes away
and it's replaced by something that
actually does this because otherwise you
could lock out what needs to happen
eventually okay that's one point
secondly i think people are far too
optimistic about the security and and
forward resistance and so on a bitcoin
bitcoin is the Bitcoin network is
dominated by about five large miners in
china and you may like to trust these
anonymous group of miners in china but i
don't and the at least two of those big
miners have been observed defrauding
people using bitcoin so the blockchain
is a great idea but it has serious
economies of scale problem the reason
it's dominated by these big miners in
china is that it's cheaper for them to
mine bitcoins than it is for anybody
else and you get the same economies of
scale problem anytime you try and build
a huge PA system I unsay is a reason why
the internet archive is the biggest
webarchive in the world is because there
are economies of scale in web archiving
and and it's really really difficult to
avoid peer-to-peer distributed systems
getting such a centralized certainly
because of economies of scale as Larry
lesyk pointed out the we've
underestimated that the power of the
network effect or these sort of this the
centralization these monopolization that
comes through some of these technologies
even email which is probably one of the
most distributed system is still alive
it's really kind of collapsing into
gmail just because we can't seem to keep
the spam out of it so III agree um we
does require a lot of work to try to
make distributed systems work we have
were fraught with failures I think the
Bitcoin think is absolutely fantastic
though because you can actually see all
the fraud structures happening it's in
this very open place where you can
actually see the blockchain split and go
through trauma where we were really
privy to that when that equivalent
happened in 2007-2008 in the United
States Federal Reserve so the I have
faith that there's a lot more faith as
probably the wrong officer observed that
they the iterations are going a lot
faster in that particular area so is it
there yet no um certainly I don't have
most of my money in in Bitcoin um but I
did pay for sushi with Bitcoin just this
last week UT this does a point for your
list Ward Cunningham who were trying to
get it's working on a new pocket that he
calls federated wiki which address a lot
of us he has working clothes hanging on
all people of all corporation his night
miss consensus let you know we're trying
to arrange for world to speak or
Cunningham yeah and you can't change so
these are great pieces been working on
these things who is we of three Dennis
and I owe me the class the lid
infrastructure our class is calling
these challenges here now is the apps a
huge increasing proportion of the time
I've all split the apps now yes and
unless you can figure out how to
incorporate the apps into your ecosystem
may be relegated to irrelevance yeah the
world wide web becomes about as useful
as ftp you know it's still useful but
not exciting then we really will have
lost something and it does seem like
we're getting a lot moved over into apps
and I wonder why um some of it is you
know well good integration within the
systems but also there's the promise of
making money is one of them and I think
it's the promise because if we look at
it they're probably about as likely to
make money as rock stars are two bit his
performance and once they actually make
effective use of the many cores within a
single process and there's one or two
orders of magnitude of a performance in
that you're not going to get with a
single threaded JavaScript so that's a
huge problem interesting point are we
getting anywhere with multi-threaded
JavaScript or people are starting the
atmosphere to curb committee that quote
JavaScript will be in forever single
ready there's been a recent legal admin
and there is performance ways to get
around it that you code differently so
you have a multiple threads of control
so I was encouraged to seeing a
Macintosh run in in JavaScript so maybe
I shouldn't be if I can see it iphone
run and in JavaScript maybe that should
be a little more prepared you can see a
highly multi-threaded okay android game
app running in javascript at performance
then they need is hope ok so on that
front you might not have heard but
rockford announced yesterday catechol
he'll be safe javascript project s ii i
ok go no doubt i should check it out I'm
sure he would argue with some of these
performance arguments about JavaScript
nonetheless it's a is trying to build a
secure financial corn
possible for Salem of the late
especially the Parker and right now
we're showing the making that secures
your messaging basically it's safe no
system no Jas probably securing it okay
I merrily as a transport layer and right
now gluing it to something called cutie
cute pecuniary not offensive anyway
hey Bella just announced it you just
okay good good you know it's going to
require this because people say yeah
JavaScript isn't actually secure as
we've been able to see you can be in one
tab and see another there's this there's
going in securing reader privacy is
really really hard and um I'm not uh
incursion to the transport layer is a
base function aunt answered a pepper is
in the room here if you mail response ok
I won't be here at Stanford this is
completely great and urs but doable or
being done I'm sorry is it doable or
being done to make JavaScript via a
distribution progress it's too early to
complain yet we're developing to be open
so it kind of pops out at home will
still be sooner the first version
available the first component is about
it but at least we need a mechanism of
moving code around that doesn't require
permission from the browser to be able
to run that it's basically a user
initiated piece of code that runs kind
of nominally at speed enough to be able
to do i would say wordpress but maybe we
have to set our our our our sights
higher on gaming to be able to make
something that's fun and interesting and
will keep people engaged and not drain
away from the open web yes we just
identified as part of a consortium of
vulnerability with using the blockchain
inappropriate watching is very good at
keeping a historical record of all the
entries of your name yes but that means
it's impossible to real to erase a
mistake it's also possible to induce
somebody to point to the
entry and use an older version rather
than the most recent of a particular
item okay and so unless the history of
the journaling is important maybe the
blockchain is not the best way to
present a snapshot of the current
version of something when that's the
thing that matters most the thing that I
find attractive about blockchain in this
discussion is some of the possibility is
doing in distributed naming structure so
it's just a just as a distributed
database of names and address pairs to
make it so we don't have to have hashes
like I love those slides that have the
people's PGP numbers on the bottom I was
like like like I'm going to type that
exactly the potential problem there
because the owner of the name is the
most recent one to claim the product key
and that can lead to problems where I
could get you to point to my entry that
was earlier in their logic so that may
not be the best solution for things with
the most recent version is the only 11
people do there's something else that I
like about Bitcoin I realize I'm i'm in
a this is a mixed crowd on the bitcoin
thing is it pops a particular truism
that i've been hearing since well ways
didn't succeed so i did a system called
ways wider information servers who claim
to fame came before gopher in the web is
awesome but the web really took off and
and one and i think of it it's not a
competition there in the sense that i
just wanted anything open to work so it
wasn't sort of another era of decnet or
SNA applied to the the content layer of
our networks and um the one of the
truisms was it has to be really really
simple right it has to be you know so
easy that you know only the simple
survives um and bitcoin um is actually
doing quite well and it's one of the
most complicated things I've seen in the
open it is wild I mean of course it's
got peer-to-peer is just part of it and
it's got this sort of that this shared
ledger system across all places it's got
crypto that actually
makes it so that I can have a
public/private key care paint and
actually have it work which I've never
been able to really get to work with my
email systems um and so it's a system
that is a really complicated was baked
enough by the time it came out that it's
actually surviving a certain level of
attack whether it's going to conquer the
well I don't know but it was the
JavaScript aha and the Bitcoin where you
can actually if you get it right you can
have a complicated system survive and
even if it's coming out of the the open
world and so thats gave me sort of gusto
to really see okay maybe we can actually
make this thing work and it's the only
way selfishly I can see to be able to
archive living websites to not just take
snapshots at the end of the day but to
actually make it so that as people want
to graduate they want to move on to
other projects they want to do whatever
that cultural institutions are going to
be sophisticated enough to be able to do
this to be able to keep these our
cultural history moving forward
otherwise we're I haven't figured it out
um just because he hasn't asked you so
how would you stop this being dominated
by spam and advertising uh probably the
same way the World Wide Web you know is
is the doesn't right I mean it just you
have you have to find your way to it but
if you find your way to at least as far
as far as that my vision is pretty
pretty shallow compared to actually you
know it's like can we build WordPress
right is then can we get it to the right
word press and know that you're there um
can you go and make that work we still
have the same navigation structures
problems of people going in spoofing and
and the like but then can we can we keep
it secure such that the administrators
stay on top of their word press doesn't
get hijacked by somebody else I think we
can do that the so that that level if we
scoped the problem to there I think we
can win another nice thing is if we
build in a business model structure then
we don't encourage people to go and put
these weird ads on it and those ads are
just bugs they're just web
synergist it feel creepy and awful I i
think his Snowden's pointed out that
we've really built a system that is
starting to be kind of creepy and that
might be another thing that puts us into
Carl's idea of going over into the
walled garden of the policed Apple
ecosystem right that if the if the open
world isn't safe we're going to retreat
so let's go and make the open world safe
to live in let's make it so we don't
aren't encouraged to try to make money
by being creepy by we have technologies
that are there that actually work that
we've actually built some systems on
that are fun to use by large numbers of
people sign here not as WordPress is not
so as they insecure I'm just yes yes so
well maybe maybe that's a maybe that's
an eight I don't think I don't think
it's an eight Carl and then we need some
way to authenticate public keys in
towards I need to know that this long
string of digits really is Brewster's
public key and not the public key of
some intelligence system middleman
that's claiming to be my Lobster Carl so
I could go down to for example the bank
and you could go down the bank of
america dedicate your public key and
they publish in a directory and then if
you're really paranoid you could go over
to wells fargo right they publish in the
directory right and then my when I go to
my contacts I worry both of them and if
they're different then there's something
is she going on but we do need that
mechanism and we do not have it down oh
I will so change one word you said not
his public key but one of his wasn't one
of your public you can s mirror all
right okay so the entire on one of them
that you haven't revoked with bank of
america so time tying I online
pseudonymous identities to real
identities should be you know the option
of those that are employing it and it
should be easy and transparent for
people that are using these to know
whether they're tied to real and
entities or not in the real world agreed
I don't have any better way of doing
that than some of the others that have
been talking about this but if we build
at least the suit anonymous structure
I'm hoping that that option go so we
don't
build a system that requires it to be
tied to real identities to begin with
because I think we'd lose too much in
terms of publishing it's actually harder
than that because you don't really want
it to be I go someplace to validate some
random string because most the time
people are not going to bother to do the
work if the string actually as the IPF s
people sort of miss is it's not just
look I p DNS names are not location or
rep typing numbers are out location DNS
names are not location there also a
notion of whom when it says disney.com I
think I know something and if it's a big
string that I got to go someplace to
figure out if it's Disney I'm now we're
going to do the validation i'm just
going to trust it burn go back to wall
garden so i've got the names have to be
in some sense self signing in a in a way
that is actually usable and it doesn't
involve going to wells fargo i can't
involve going to wells fargo so there is
a way to do that is easy to do it
together but you had to bake the name in
the encryptions so I don't ask I want to
question the centrality of identity that
you put in there I actually think
identifier is important but that
necessarily making identity central is
not important it's an identity system in
the sense that their blog will know it's
you coming back so you need at least
that level of sort of here are the
admins for this website and then they
can go and one who has permission to set
of permissions that happen to map to
what the admin can do you can do that
without identity and identity in a sense
of knowing who the human is identity i'm
getting over money yes so the basic
items we often use identity as a proxy
for really want and i think you're doing
that so in particular when i make a
request of your service what's the most
important question you should ask I
don't know what should you honor the
request am i authorized to make this
request and you don't need identity to
do that I could present an access token
right I guess I'm thinking that we're
already there I
I think whatever you are we because it
gets into deeper than I can get pretty
quickly yes who this verse pants a
little you're going to have to speak out
because nobody can argue about okay it's
on my list of things try to figure out
how to its kind of ambitious exactly who
directed which is to build an ultimately
totally private real situation hi okay
so the thing that can solve this but I
think interesting though smart people
around me couple things meeting that way
we can really put many terabytes info we
can fill any crash of every night over
that everything's between speak for the
universe per second which means i can
pull everything that's public down to my
phone and just the Condors of my phone
which the cumulative experience of my
interest in whatever which stays on the
phone okay and browse through all the
folks at further they got I don't want
and then just pull everything in that I
want this is a throwing up second one
but you also what that it right so keep
the channel full of noise I now have a
lot of stuff sorted from even more stuff
daily basis I say five terabyte and that
if you build something that allows me to
pull stuff privately and yes i can make
very snappy after it's been on the phone
for one night I want that if you're from
Samsung you're gonna give me a terabyte
phone I'll take it um also make it so
that there's cheap enough valuable than
a 64 megabytes phone because its proper
cuz part of it if we have enough of a
channel that we can go in and waste some
of our bandwidth I think it's absolutely
is not
pactera boys JavaScript so that when you
go there it's darling home telling them
exactly its dude about everybody
download to your phone will be three
speeds into charger is exactly less than
an hour to focus in a Georgia right
thing if you haven't have access to the
Internet in a low-cost way pulling a
terabyte into a phone costs nothing fun
isn't like that anymore it's not static
content that you download and we do it
is anybody miss anything to say these
archiving it I said at least a day
before I let everybody know that I make
it's not HTML anyone gonna scream I'm
not making that guard I make the
argument that content it is more than a
day's worth of information it's red
after a day I'm not getting across your
idea that it's private depends on the
idea that you download it and then read
it and it doesn't talk to the outside
world that's the way the web was ten
years ago it's not the way the way
there's any moment the weight of the way
the way you read sites is you get to
JavaScript which incrementally loads the
site as you reading okay okay there is
Lisa huge a JavaScript he's right if you
excuse me if you take WordPress right
now we go and use centralized resources
on that website to go and do the search
engine in the database function to go
and show that you can actually download
that given the current bandwidths as I I
did it for a dorky little site and would
it work for Wikipedia actually maybe
interestingly but most sites are not as
even big as it would work for Google
absolutely not but there are awful lot
of sites that if we code it right can be
distributed in such a way that you don't
need to touch the server for things when
we were doing the original web you often
these things were tied to an
organization this was a way of a face of
an organization and we tied to it
because it used some resources at the
place but more and more of the web
communities I'm seeing are tied less and
less to institutions they actually just
live in the cloud and if they live in
the cloud then they can be encapsulated
and ported around some of its functional
some of its code and some of its static
but that is actually movable just based
on the computing capabilities that are
now in phones thanks these guys as well
as well as some of the bandwidth so as
at least we think going for a large
sector of what we currently uses the web
and I think it can still be fun and
interesting and playful on to answer
some of Karl's complaints about you know
is this going to be good enough to do
games I think we can do interesting
things with things with movable websites
that would be able to be hosted in
multiple places and transported around
that's that's my just by watching how
most websites work yep I am in this
sense a very nice person okay I have
been told by friends and dealt with
Laura stated that you are now at point
of generating approximately one got a
bite of content a year it goes up the
terabyte is nothing terabyte is
invisible buddy says we have a billion
smart reviews with a terabyte each have
that terabyte see the question is what
is their care but you need to have and
why can it be out fresh every night in
an hour but some cases it's a lot of
terabytes times building so the best
your amid the work that we're moving
along on our storage technology and some
of those some of these numbers that
you're coming across are based on how
cheap it is to store it but movies um or
textual websites dominantly Web Audio
websites um they're they're not getting
that much bigger each I mean they can
get bigger because the technologies are
making it so but there's a there's a
class that works quite well we don't
have to be able to pour it around
everything to be able to make a system
work for a very large number of people
that want to publish privately they want
to read privately they
like to have sort of this get type of
function to to their websites that there
is a class that this could work very
very well for it does that that's that's
the argument I agree that it's a class a
little bout a walls for example they
want me to pay for the content that
would require a phone home and that
would require and on what I'd see there
are websites now unnecessarily their
work sites now that our one-page it's
all JavaScript there's one URL and it
just changes all the time and what you
see depends on what you did and there's
no way to predict all possible human
interactions with that page that's fine
but so while you don't do it for much
content there's much content that that
won't work okay okay you need to read a
paper by George's couldn't access and
Monica chew of the web to double
security and privacy bookshop call
tracking protection for firefox in
Firefox for progress into fools it gives
you some idea of what is actually going
on with popular websites yes it's
perfectly true that things like my blog
and so on which are completely
irrelevant even written in the web of
things that you could read private but
things like the new york times or
something like that if you turn on
firefox Tracking Protection you get rid
of about where was it if it's about
two-thirds of the total data download
and almost all of that is completely
invisible to the reader it's there
because it's gathering young's modulus
is encouraging right that there's the
base bit you know even the New York
Times is bugging the hell out of us so
uh so let's go and find a mechanism not
only that we have the technologies for
ourselves for your blog which actually
isn't completely worthless um but to
make it to the New York Times could find
a way of going and publishing online
without feeling that it's gotta go and
rent out its its mailing list to
everybody and their brother to try to
make it work and I think we can do this
I don't think we have to have phone home
to be able to make money the ransomware
guys are actually figuring some of this
out that's not a great model to go and
follow but the idea of being able to go
and
hold something encrypted until you go
and pay with set a Bitcoin to go and
unencrypted it is showing that it is
possible to try to sell something over
the internet without revealing who you
are and so not great guys to follow but
it's at least a proof of concept that we
can actually make a billing system that
works yes now it's just you're right so
much tell you tale 180 phones for your
apple and some more no wait a
here in Times not like the content
quietly phone that's designed
differently for people who want privacy
it's no I are so there's a very yummy
here's you don't need to the argument is
that we can make a world wide web that
works even if apple and samsung and
google and those guys don't agree if we
can then that's just trying to think
ahead is really good economic reason to
make it private phone oh I would find
there is no reason to believe make no
you cannot reason because if people care
they wouldn't cost a thousand dollars
which apply to certified phone from the
Defense Department phones we've shown
repeatedly that people give away
passwords for a cooking a chocolate chip
cookies that's not what really is when
kymaro must be and you know if we didn't
have some fun people we've got this big
conversation I'm speaking most but then
there's as long it's a very long tail
I'd like to hear from the rest of the
long tail where we're about it and an
hour is there any comments that people
would like to do before we sort of sum
up this is a call to action it's a
basically a tessellation of explanations
that there are technologies that can go
and caused this I PFS was a quan Bennett
who is here a couple weeks ago showed
pieces of this arm it's really a is it
desirable enough to work together to try
to get it here and just would like to
you know a lot long tail yes heroes
you're still in the fat tail listen to
the arguments and I gotta say I think
Bruce is got something here I would want
to support it hey okay there's a basis
of year I think
problems on our but not insurmountable
and I think we need some fresh thinking
to disclose the gap on the violations
give anything else you don't have to say
reimbursed or just anything else in
there does
you